the g7 climate busters have arrived in
carbus bay england from all around the
globe to meet up for a bit of a
champagne chinwag about vaccines
trade and climate change and they've
already upset
the locals let's have a little peek
it's joe biden's debut on the world
stage and after traveling 6 000
kilometers on the fuel sloping air force
one followed by
massive fleet helicopters from the us to
raf mildenhall in suffolk england to
tell american soldiers he'll say to
president putin that he wants to
let him know what i want him to know
they're jumping back on air force one
followed by a massive fleet of
helicopters you must use that zero
carbon fuel
arriving another six hundred kilometers
away in carbes bay to head the climate
charge with the g7 crew and have a
barbecue and some toasted marshmallows
the host of the event
british prime minister boris johnson
took a private jet 400 kilometers from
london to cornwall
he must use that zero carbon fuel as
well or
does that even exist no zero carbon
technology options are currently
available for commercial aviation
boris has wasted no time to impress joe
biden
hoping to keep the us uk relationship
alive he described their meeting last
night as a
breath of fresh air and said biden
brought a lot of love with him
from the u.s but it doesn't sound like
that for the people that live in carvis
bay
listen to what this local told the press
association
it's totally inappropriate it's not
climate friendly it's a total waste of
money
they've closed a hospital they've closed
our police station and they are wasting
millions and millions of pounds for
international people to have a party
some residents have moved out of the
area until the event is over because of
major rail and road disruption and the
homeless have been pushed out of their
temporary accommodation
all g7 countries have promised to be net
zero by 2050 and if the thousands of air
miles clocked up by this meeting or
anything to go by and they've not made
the best of stars
but you do have to give it to them they
somehow manage to stick to the old adage
do as we say
but not as we do then again zoom
meetings are a bit passe nowadays